in this video we'll talk about the
applications of 2d and 3d cell culture
systems in my earlier videos i've talked
about what is cell culture what are the
applications what are the reagents media
used for it so i have an entire playlist
for cell culture do check it out and you
would get the link in the i button
in this video we'll talk about the
application portion cell culture
is
really used in several labs all across
the world and it allows researcher to
grow cells outside of the body in an
artificial settings
in this video we'll talk about the
biomedical applications of cell culture
clinical applications and biotic
industry related applications of cell
culture system
so let's begin this video by looking at
the application of cell culture in
clinical settings
cell lines are used to
diagnose diseases and one such example
is the diagnosis of
autoimmune diseases
and one test that is performed is known
as
anti-nuclear antigen test or ana test
which looks for antinuclear antibodies
present in the blood
so
patients such as who are suffering from
systemic lupus erythematosus
will show a positive ana test
in this test
hep two cell lines are used
if you don't know what is cell line
click on the i button you would get the
cell line related video
hip to cell lines are enriched in
nuclear antigens
so you take samples from the patient
body one possibility is it might have
these anti-nuclear antibodies
another possibility is it doesn't have
any anti-nuclear antibodies
anyway you put this antibodies
or this patient sample
on these cell culture
and then do a immunofluorescence
if there is an antinuclear antibody a
fluorescent level secondary antibody
will surely detect it and give rise to
fluorescence by looking at the
fluorescent pattern one can understand
whether there is an
autoimmune disorder or not where there
is auto antibodies
there or not and the fluorescence
pattern actually correlates with several
diseases and a doctor can understand
which pattern correspond to what disease
so now in short we understood how
cell culture could be used to interpret
disease results
let me give you another example
let's say you are preparing a drug which
can possibly prevent growth of cancer
cells
before this drug can be
tested in several clinical trials
it has to be first
analyzed in a preclinical
settings
in this preclinical stage
it is generally tested on cell cultures
that's why it is really important
cell cultures can allow the researcher
to test the efficacy of a drug so let's
say this is a particular cell culture
and you are testing several cancer drugs
and you want to understand which drug is
the most potent one all of these are
synthetic drugs and you are wondering
which one has the best effect and after
testing on the cell culture you find
that this particular drug has the
maximal effect
that means you would proceed with this
drug and test it on animals and then
eventually it might enter a clinical
trial
recently stem cell therapy is gaining
huge popularity
and in order to perform stem cell
therapy
a clinical setting requires cell culture
systems so let me example give you an
example to understand let's say you have
a third degree burn
so
in that case you need
grafts that can
possibly heal and
allow your recovery of that burned
region in the skin
but many of the cases what happens graph
is getting rejected due to
immune activation and inflammation in
this area because this graft is probably
taken from somebody else or some other
location of your body so there could be
problem
now in this case
scientists have developed stem cell
therapies where they take skin cells
from the same patient
they convert these skin cells with a
magic cocktail
to induce pluripotent stem cells
and from this induced pluripotent stem
cell they can grow artificial skin and
transplant that skin into this injured
area this ensures enhanced
recovery process and doesn't allow graft
rejection because this cells are taken
from the same body
so
the immune system should not
consider it as foreign similar strategy
can be used for
eye treatment for example there is an
inflammation or death in the retinal
cells one can take stem cell from the
same patient convert that stem cell into
retinal cells and that is possible these
days with specific morphogens and
instructions that can be provided into
the cell culture and then ultimately
these cells can be replacing the damaged
and decaying cells in the retina that
can give vision to this particular
patient how cool is that
now thinking about specific diseases you
can think about cancer and in cancer let
me give you one example
tumor cells are often targeted by the nk
cells because tumor cell doesn't have
class 1 mhc
and
nk cells can
target this tumor cell based on that so
obviously if you can trigger n-k
cell-mediated response in your body
possibly you can have a healing effect
on tumor
this individual here is suffering from a
particular type of cancer and you can
see a tumor here
so one possibility is like you can take
out the
nk cells from this particular patient's
body
then cultured them and in that culture
add such certain cytokines which can
activate these
nk cells this can make these nk cells
proactive and
that is and then further you can inject
that into the same patient's body into
the tumor site that means they would be
more efficient in terms of fighting the
tumor when you are activating them and
that is possible with the advancement of
cell culture that brings out the
advantage why cell culture is crucial
for
medical purposes
now let's talk about importance of cell
culture in biomedical research
we are not going to delve into details
but cell culture systems are used for
several fundamental scientific question
for example you want to learn about a
localization of a protein you can use a
cell to understand where this particular
protein is localized either by doing
immunohistochemistry or let's say you
can do it by fluorescent tagging
let's say you want to learn whether two
proteins are interacting or not in a
cellular setting so you can do that
inside a cell you can do
fret based acids
you can also do disease modeling using
this particular cells
also you can test the effect of a drug
or effect of us environmental stressor
on cells and try to understand what's
the detrimental effect
all of this thing is possible with the
advancement of cell culture
let's say you want to test the efficacy
of a drug you can do that in cell
culture you treat it with different
concentration of drug and see whether it
triggers some kind of apoptosis response
or not this is just one of the example
i'm giving you
now let's talk about the
implications of cell culture in biotech
industry now biotech in biotech
industries cell culture is now a really
important part
in biotech industry you culture cells
but in order of thousand liter volume
where you culture let's say some 10 ml
of cell culture you have basically
1000 liter of cell culture in an
industry setting compared to a research
or a lab settings
so for these cell cultures can
allow us to develop products that are
used in daily life for example
production of insulin that is required
for us
let me break it down for you let's say
you are a researcher and you need a
antibody or let's say you need a
restriction enzyme for your research
work or let's say a recombinant protein
is required
now what you do is you call the industry
people
and you ask them to deliver a particular
protein with a particular catalog number
now that particular guy delivers it to
your doorstep but do you know what
really happens in the industry in the
industry in the bioreactor
they create these products
and in order to create these products
they need cell culture based system for
example they are preparing an antibody
they need hybridoma cell lines right and
that hybridoma cell lines need to be
amplified in order of thousands and
thousands of liters such that they can
generate
antibodies in order of grams
and only few milligrams is delivered to
your doorstep
so now we understand how this is really
important in an industrial setting in
order to understand what is
bioprocessing how bioreactors work you
can click on the video in the i button
but in this video
let me give you a very quick heads up
towards a 3d culture system
these days scientist has discovered a
new technique called organoid which is a
3d
culture which resembles organs this
these are also known as mini organs
this has revolutionized medicine and the
way we think about medicine
organoids has multiple applications
from understanding disease mechanism to
the fundamental development organoid has
been
a game changer in the field of medicine
you can study disease mechanism
toxicology development and stem cell
biology regenerative medicine drug
discovery and the progression of
infectious disease in these in vitro 3d
culture systems in a different video
i'll talk about organoids in bit more
details let me know whether you want a
separate video or not
but anyway it would be available in the
i button
so in this video what we learned is
basically
the application of cell culture in the
field of biomedical research clinical
application and
application of cell culture in industry
notes regarding this video would be
available in my facebook page very soon
you can get many interactive flash card
dynamic flash card in my facebook page
also in the community post so check them
out
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support my channel in
patreon if you're an indian viewer you
can support my channel in bim upi app
you can
also take my unacademic courses using my
code ap10 you can get a 10 discount all
my social media links are provided in
the description feel free to connect to
me and i will be really happy to help
and give any advice to you guys thanks a
lot for listening see you in next video